I had a long argument with uh with Taja
Gracie when he visited and he thinks
malt is the most dominant position
even Noki
uh versus back would you is there a case
to be made for that or no dude I think I
think all of your opponent's utensils
their tools are in front of them so like
if you're on Mount they still have you
know there's a few ways to get out of
them out I think if you're on somebody's
back I personally much rather be on
somebody's back than flattened out I'd
rather have someone's back and then
flattened out boots in flattened out
yeah yeah boots and flying out so not
not even body triangle but just
flattened just completely flat almost
like a position in my way you see guys
get finished because they can't get out
I think that position is probably the
hardest position to escape can you see
what hodger's talking about with Mount
RC just that good at Mount like he says
that he might mean the gay cross color
you know I don't know I didn't mean this
is controlling wise he just believes
that you can complete that there's
he actually thinks there's more ways to
get out from the back of the nurse from
the mount prior to getting up including
like physically prior to the Kipping
Escape
I'll probably agree with him but they're
keeping escapes so difficult to manage
it's the funny looking Escape we uh yeah
people have a lot of trouble it's like
super hard to learn how to do but then
once you learn how to do it the
effectiveness is just huge yeah it's a
weird one when did that come to be a
thing
is that pretty recent well I mean I saw
DDS guys using it first I think yeah
who's the first guy to discover
something like that this seems like a
ridiculous thing to discover yeah I'm
gonna fight this wiggle
I thought it was a joke at first I was
you guys really doing this yeah
I remember somebody's showing me like a
technique where uh like if you just like
walk your hand on a mat or something
like that maybe on a triangle or
something yeah yeah
and it's just like a funny Discovery
like as opposed to like trying to like
shove it in just like walk it I like
doing that to people but with things
that aren't true
you know what I mean I'll just tell them
this is a technique and watch him
try to work out if I'm being serious or
not yeah that's what you do when you
achieve Guru status they'll just listen
to you like you're Steven Seagal see
what they'll believe